عندما يتعلق الامر بالحقوق والحريات تسير
المراه الافغانيه في حقل انغام انغام
وضعتها حركه طالبان منذ توليها السلطه
لعزل المراه وهدم اي دور لها في المجتمع
وامام قرارات طالبان الاخيره بحرمان
المراه من التعليم والعمل لم يعد الامر
يتوقفوا على تمديدات او ضغوطات دوليه بل
يتطلب الامر بحسب ناشطنا افغان تحركات
مدنيه من داخل افغانستان لكن رغم كل
التمديدات والتحذيرات تصمم الحركه على
انتهاكاتها ورفع سقف التحدي
[موسيقى]
وفي اطار التحركات الدوليه للضغط على
طالبان قال قبل قليل وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه جيمس كليبر الطالبان تسعى
لاقصاء النساء من المجتمع عبر حظر عملهم
في المنظمات الدوليه فيما التقى اليوم
رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده في افغانستان مع
وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان وحثه هو
على الغاء القرار المتعلق بحضر عمل
الافغانيات وفي بيان لبعثه الامم المتحده
اشار المبعوث الى ان الملايين الافغان
يحتاجون الى المساعدات الانسانيه وتذليل
العقبات لكن الطالبان لم ترد ولم تعلق
من جانبها اعلنت منظمتاه الاغاثه كريش 8
واكشن ايد تعليق نشطهما في افغانستان بعد
ان امر طالبان بحضر عمل النساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه ما يرفع الاجمالي
الى ست منظمات اتخذت خطوه مماثره وحتى
منظمه كرستيشن ايد البريطانيه طالبا على
الغاء الحظر معربه عن اسفها لتعليق عملها
في افغانستان